polonia cambió la agenda de la cumbre
europea el estado de derecho y el
alcance de las competencias del bloque
tomaron el centro de la escena luego de
que el tribunal constitucional polaco
dictará que el derecho comunitario no
puede estar por encima de la carta magna
nacional un elemento más en la larga
disputa entre bruselas y varsovia para
la máxima líder de la comisión europea
eso amenaza un principio fundamental de
la unión
la cuestión central es la independencia
del poder judicial en polonia esto no es
nuevo es un proceso en curso pero con la
reciente sentencia del tribunal
constitucional esto está tomando una
nueva dimensión así que espero con
ansias las discusiones con los líderes
todos tenemos que asumir una
responsabilidad cuando se trata de
proteger nuestros valores fundamentales
aún fundamentales polonia cuestiona la
primacía del derecho comunitario y
rechaza posibles sanciones a las que
cataloga de amenazas
yo no vamos a actuar bajo la presión del
chantaje estamos listos para el diálogo
no estamos de acuerdo con la gama cada
vez mayor de competencias de la unión
europea pero por supuesto
cómo resolver las disputas actuales con
comprensión y diálogo yo lo que la
cumbre también marcará la despedida de
la canciller alemana angela merkel para
ella es una posibilidad de repensar el
rol de la unión
como en los distintos estados miembros
de la unión europea su futuro es la
unión cada vez más estrecha que plantea
una de las partes o es simplemente una
colección de estados naciones la
conferencia para el futuro de europa es
un buen lugar para hacernos estas
preguntas unos a otros me está dando a
descubrir cómo hacer frente al alza de
precios de la energía y las diferencias
en la lucha contra el hobbit 19 sobre
todo en la vacunación fueron otros temas
en la agenda el debate continuará el
viernes y se centrará en el manejo de la
migración y el desarrollo de la política
digital del bloque